[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing a topic that i saw requested
in the comment section
below it's a topic that i've covered
before but not very well
and today i want to do it justice we're
going to be discussing spells
but not just any aspect of spells we're
going to be discussing the
visual component to a spell now there
are all sorts of spells and
all kinds of different incantations but
one thing is for certain
the colour of a spell always attracts a
lot of attention
voldemort zavada kadavra just wouldn't
be the same without that sinister
looking jet of green light
emanating from his wand and nor would
harry's bright red
expelliarmus but what i want to discuss
today
is what do these different spell colours
actually mean
are they simply arbitrary or are we able
to derive
some sort of relationship between the
color of the spell
and the type of spell itself what is the
underlying meaning
behind these spell colors i think that
the most obvious and sort of
go-to answer to this relatively
unaddressed question
is something like green spells are
inherently dark in nature
red spells are inherently powerful in
nature and white spells are inherently
pure good and passive in nature to name
a few
and i agree with those sentiments for
the most part however i believe there is
much more to it than that
and i want to peel back the layers and
uncover what it is that makes these
spells
these colours let's start by looking at
a couple of common spell colors
green throughout history has always been
regarded as having some sort of
supernatural connection it is also
commonly associated with dark magic
and is coincidentally the same color as
the house of slytherin
which gets a bit of a bad rap for its
affiliation
with dark witches and wizards
slytherin's house colors
which are green and silver are said to
be connected to the element
that they most closely represent which
is water
the killing curse itself is green which
is pretty much as dark and sinister as
you can get
so i understand this common connection
between green and evil
furthermore spells cast with the intent
of death or suffering
almost always seem to be green green can
be extremely varied
depending on what shade of green you are
talking about but across a broad sample
of different greens
it can still be shown as implying
toxicity illness
jealousy and potentially envy some
examples of what i would consider to be
typically
green spells include avada kadavra the
killing curse
imperio which places the victim
completely under the caster's control
and mulmort which conjures an enormous
eerie image of the dark mark
red on the other hand is generally
regarded as being representative of
energy
passion and fire red along with gold
represents gryffindor house this is
consistent with the house's element
which is fire red spells are often
powerful
and bear the potential to be destructive
in nature like green spells
but aren't necessarily evil or sinister
they are more likely to be used
defensively than offensively
that is not to say that they couldn't be
used offensively if the cast are wanted
but these spells are less commonly used
to kill or cause suffering to an enemy
harry's signature spell expelliarmus
proves to be extremely useful for him
but while fairly powerful it just
doesn't have the same feeling of
darkness that we see in a number of
strictly offensive
green spells somehow it feels as if it
is cast with the best intent
red has an unspoken but seemingly
implicit element of warmth
comfort and security some examples of
what i would consider to be typically
red spells include expelliarmus which
forces whatever an opponent is holding
to fly out of their hand
stupefy which stuns the target rendering
them unconscious
incendio which countries of jet of
flames and fiend fire which is a flame
of abnormal size and heat
however fiendfire is the obvious
exception here as it is actually quite a
dark spell
a classic example of a white spell is
the patronus which is bright white and
emphasizes hope
purity and positivity it is somewhat
antithetical to spells which are
representative of
darkness this explains what is so
effective at warding off dementors
as it represents the very things that
dementors aren't
it drives away darkness and dark things
and it's powerful
but in most circumstances isn't
destructive
it isn't often used offensively and it
only exists to ward off
dark and sinister things i think that
red and green are sort of the main
powerhouse spell colors in the harry
potter universe
and that all other spell colors sort of
circumvent these primary colors
green and red almost have a sort of ian
and yang relationship
where they are both powerful but
represent very different things
i think that the other colors share
common attributes such as being
representative of elements
but despite there being powerful spells
which use these colours i think they are
less closely tied to a sort of
underlying meaning
some blue spells include reducto which
is a curse that blasts solid objects to
pieces
aguamenti which conjures a jet of clean
drinkable water
and immobilis which immobilizes and
stops the actions of the target
as you can see these spells are not
necessarily as closely related
as say a grouping of red spells or a
grouping of green spells
the same can be said for other spell
colours as there is a less identifiable
relationship between different spells
that utilize the same color this all
sounds great
right okay now let's look at exceptions
to these general rules
that i've sort of tried to establish
this is where it begins to break down
a little bit exhibit a sektum sempra
sektim sempra is an extremely vicious
offensive spell
that causes cuts and lacerations on the
target it was created by severus snape
with the intention of using it against
his enemies by describing it it sounds
like it would fit into the same category
as avada kadavra as the only objective
of casting it
is to cause pain and suffering however
sektum sempra
is actually white exhibit b crucio
crucio is one of the most sinister
curses and is used to cause intense and
excruciating pain upon a victim
once again this sort of sounds like it
fits into the wheelhouse of
green spells and it sounds as if it
would come from the same category
as zavada kadavra wrong it is actually
red
this is where i'm forced to get a bit
more abstract in my thinking
i think this is where standards for what
spell colors represent
might be skewed it is my belief that the
color of the spell can be heavily
influenced by the spell caster
and that the colour is not necessarily
purely determined by the spell itself
this blurs the lines a bit and
essentially what i'm suggesting
is that the relationship between spell
and spell color
is more fluid than we might have
originally thought i think that's
something we need to consider
is that the color may be influenced by
how it is being used and by whom
in almost every instance that we've seen
avada kadavra being used
it is a green jet of light i think that
it is undeniably a green spell
in almost every circumstance and the
spell itself
is green because of its inherently dark
nature
however when snape kills dumbledore in
the half-blood prince
he actually uses avada kadavra the
unusual thing about this scene
is that the jet of light that snape
produces is definitely more on the blue
side
and not the shade of green that we're
used to this could obviously just come
down to the filmmaker's preference
but it definitely looks kind of blue my
theory is
the richer the color the more closely
resembles the values
that it is meant to represent in its
purest form i.e
the purer the green the more evil the
purer the red
the more powerful if a typically green
spell like avada kedavra is cast with
that intention
that matches what the spell itself
represents then it will be produced in a
different color
snape clearly had hesitation when
killing dumbledore and his true
emotional state was represented
in the color of the spell because snape
didn't want to kill dumbledore
his reluctance showed in the color of
the spell that he produced
i want to discuss this aspect of the
video further but i'll save it for the
next one
obviously there are other spells besides
red green and white
i've just mainly mentioned these because
they seem to be most prevalent
one interesting instance of a purple
spell comes from antonin
dolohov who seems to be able to produce
an offensive curse in the shade of
purple
but the death eater hermione had just
struck dumb
made a sudden slashing movement with his
wand a streak of what looked like purple
flame
passed right across hermione's chest she
gave a tiny oh
as though of surprise and crumpled onto
the floor where she lay motionless
i think that it makes sense the dollar
hob's curse is purple because
like some shades of green purple implies
certain things
like witchcraft deviousness and
sometimes even toxicity
i'll end the video here because i think
there are so many angles that you can
look at this from
when you've seemingly identified a
relationship between spell color and
spell
there always seems to be an exception to
the rule and that's what makes this
topic fairly convoluted
and difficult to discuss i'd love to
hear what you guys have to say on this
topic
what do you think spell colors represent
are they bound by meaning or entirely
arbitrary that's it for this video until
next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live